I think we've gone through about four
strategies of things to do but I was
intrigued by something you said which
was to to know how to avoid common
mistakes what do you see as common
mistakes that people make in career
transitions so I mean the first is we
talked about it be realistic I mean a
this is not easy be it can take time you
may fail you may go down a path that
doesn't work so you have to regroup but
you've gotta you've got to know that
you're gonna make it it's gonna be okay
but you've got to be realistic about it
and you know very closely connected is
be patient right because it can take
time hard-won some time you know
lightning could strike and it does but
more likely you're gonna have to
navigate this and figure it out and give
yourself enough time and enough space to
to do it and that's why you know Project
Work is actually an interesting way to
keep yourself busy as you go through
this because often times that can turn
into something that you don't expect
right right well and also it seems like
there's some phrase that you've used
several times that I've always liked
which is embrace the serendipity is that
opportunities may come up you may not be
ready for them or even want them or you
may think you want them but you really
should really and you know it's there's
sort of sweet things that are connected
you know hey you've got to be realistic
you've got to be patient but you've also
got to roll up your sleeves you may have
to take a step back you may have to do
things that feel uncomfortable right but
again you're trying to forge your way
into something new right and so like
anything new you know it's gonna feel a
little uncomfortable you're gonna have
to do some things also we always talk
about the importance of teamwork which
is of course important when you're
pivoting you have to think of yourself
as a new a new worker a new employee and
you want to figure out how you can make
an individual impact you want to show
that you can make a contribution and you
want to make it in a way that lets
people understand it's going to work and
be the team player but also be very
clear on what you're bringing right to
personal value and and then it's
serendipity is just just something
you've always said that you know it
it's actually as I said the the career
that is pivoting is gonna be unique to
everybody and so one of the reasons that
you want to be fluid and opportunistic
is you know I look at my own career I
could never have written down law to
Investment Banking to government to you
know media to venture capital you know
you would never have seen that it's a
combination of following what you're
interested in but being nimble and when
the opportunity comes up so media is a
really good example and this is kind of
another thing for career pivots that I
think people should just keep in mind I
got an opportunity to go into media
precisely because I knew nothing about
it and it was a situation where there
had been an attempt to create a new
market and the people who knew a lot
about that market were very rigid in
their thinking and they said I know how
to do this and of course it's a new
market so sometimes knowledge can be an
obstacle not I'm not a plus so they so
they glad they were glad you're a clue
they were glad I didn't know anything
and so again you know you that's being
nimble like I didn't expect that I could
walk into an opportunity in media cuz I
knew nothing about media I had no media
in my background I got lucky
right found something that was so I
think it's just keeping your eyes open
being receptive to things that you
hadn't thought of but that might work
and trying them and there the other
thing you said which I don't want to you
know skip over is the get your hands
dirty like yes may if you're making a
career transition or pivot you may have
to do something that you you may think
was below you or that you write exactly
skills were beyond exactly you do it you
do it because you know where you're
going and you know the thing that's
interesting about this whole area is
we're talking a lot about what an
individual needs to do to be successful
in a career pivot employers now have to
think more broadly about people's career
and how to evaluate that because it's
not gonna look like it's always looked
and so the ability to understand that
people are pursuing different different
things at different times and to be able
to assess and evaluate the quality of
that individual even though it's a lot
harder yeah then it used to be when
you said okay they advanced up in two
point six months and so I think it's a
new skill for employers to to be aware
that this is happening at the rate that
it's happening and to adjust their own
expectations and skills honestly in
order to recognize the great talent
that's out there that is pursuing a
different path it really does feel like
a new normal I think I think we're gonna
see more and more people who both again
by choice or by by happenstance are
finding themselves looking to make a
career pivot and I think they should
feel excited about that opportunity and
excited about where it might take them